[Music]
hello everyone I can't actually hear my
own voice cuz I unplugged my headset so
this is kind of awkward Wow how how yeah
that's probably on Luke just kidding
you're not you're not John but this is
definitely Monster Hunter Fridays yes it
is
I'm just taking his place and luckily
for for him
our boy devil Joe is not actually out
yet but it's coming soon he's gonna be
out next week so we're just gonna do
some preparations mild corporations and
check out some of the the weekly stuff
that's kind of come back into the game
this week as energy buzz back got a
really cool quest for for doing that
there you are I should go to the
gathering not up there right now oh well
you're on your way here let's remind the
chat that like every other show you can
join us using this wonderful code down
here along the bottom of our camera and
you can join us we're on the PlayStation
4 come hunt with us I'm coming with your
friends I just went to the workshop you
know sometimes you just got to go to the
workshop oh but all right I'm gonna have
to pick something else to you because
you know what yeah it's not there for
some reason I was gonna say I can't I
can't see just wait to my room I can't
see my pals [ __ ] hold on I'll fix
everything that's okay we're doing it
live then everything is live today also
we're gonna possibly do something else
live later too and we'll talk about that
more later
yeah fixed is other steps stay stay
tuned
so what we're dealing with today is
there something like 3d actually there
isn't that many but I know like if
you're missing Zener jiva parts like I
was like there's an event for it so it
makes it easier than you just trying to
find you know the the quest or the like
investigation not investigations like
the the thing that pops up every now and
then like minds for whatever reason
actually popped up cuz I can hear the
music yeah so the first one I think
we're going to be hitting up I think
this is I'm pretty sure this is new
because I don't remember doing it is the
second challenge quest which is low
ranked arena stuff gotta be a good time
and then over here we've also got
the majority of the content we're gonna
be hitting up which is a double oregon
fight and a Xena Jeeva fight sounds like
fun so should be a good time I think
there we go
chats back what hello hello Bob how are
you doing looking good
also I like that that's the first
message that pops up yeah pretty much
how it goes
usually it is how it goes oh you're in
here hell I am I've been you've made uh
hi Ronan hi Asia's hello Joey
what's up Ryan Rayner Reiner who's knee
says he's sexy anyways what do you want
to do here we're gonna do I was it that
every time is a good question you know
you gotta wonder sometimes so I think
the best option right now since we're
waiting for people to get in we can post
up the arena quests because I think it's
only two people anyway okay so it'll be
that'll be for us to warm up and get
ready to get carried by everyone then
you know I don't get put in a backpack
you know what's gonna be great we're
both gonna be using switch axe for this
and I'm pulling it
what so you want to get trip now you're
using charge blade alright so for the
arena but oh yeah fair I'm switch axe
for life until maybe I switched a
greatsword because of that buff coming
but it will probably be real weird to do
that or do I have to join up you know
get on in here I don't oh that's weird
I thought it just populates oh no you've
got to join the quest that I post up
alright okay
I've so load most of this game that's
totally fair
and that I think does a good job
speaking to how well they handle doing
single-player stuff and see there you go
this will be easier this is not really
fast yeah
just just to say we did it but yeah I am
actually trying to learn how to use a
charge blade and I've never touched it
only doing that because why to get ready
for the Dante stuff yeah
because hey his his sword is for some
reason to charge blade is weird like
apparently it still blocks even though
Oh a do we need to eat first so you
don't even need to eat because
everything is all on site this is like
the Metal Gear Solid 3 of monster on
request okay I'm gonna say good and
we're good to go what's up Jimmy
hi fanboy glad your name is Jeff my name
is Jeff I like Jack huh you know I might
mainly because I don't know these other
weapons wow that looks real because the
captain's hat I might use the bug stick
hang on on one switch mix it up although
it didn't matter this is such a low
level I guess I could have just sold
anything
this is no it's low rank but they're
giving us a low rank gear to match with
it yeah oh it's more fair so we're still
doing like the fight as a fight but it's
a show of our skill epidemics that
sponsor fund a Friday's show my favorite
also hello epidemic looking good yeah so
where's the dust one eat so it's all in
your inventory each each class has its
own loadout of stuff to kind of get so
you got to eat like a well done steak
use a max potion to get your health up
I'm gonna use that later so you don't do
that right now
oh no I do it right now you just save
that man go to second 10 mega potions
I'm ready to go dude all right so often
well you ready plan I'm gonna go and
that's quick no we don't I'm gonna
separate these I'll kill this birdie oh
you know what sucks we don't have any I
can't separate it out it's chasing you
this is fine this is okay alright that
oh we're already already off to a great
start over alla fine
say I already got my my read extract so
I'm trying to just keep why I'm just
gonna miss a bit trying to kil twice oh
you wanna get tripped my monster hunter
flow there we go
straight into a mount this is good here
you know what while you do that I'll
just you know sharpen my blade oh yeah
go for it why don't you do it like yes
right here not him does it do you have
we figured out if it actually like
affects you if I'm actually attacking it
more so I I don't think it does I know
that back when they first introduced
mounting you had to like have everyone
back off whenever you got on cuz you
would actually knock people yeah exactly
you didn't want to keep attack I don't
think that happens in this game right
yeah I don't think it happens in this
one either god this feels so weak I'm I
got no like weakness exploit I got none
of your stuff is here this is this is a
lawless lawless my I just said it would
be huh we don't have any flash pods huh
um me are you real sweet right now I
don't got paralysis knifes though tell
me get down get to the choppa there we
go
don't mind me on your leg here
that's good that was real good thanks I
kind of kind of regretting not picking
the switch axe I'm like man that one
combo does so much though switch axe is
so much fun and it's gonna get a little
bit better too with the patch oh hello
found him I think you got me that time
it's very possible use that net baby hey
I ran away
can't believe this typical you know you
slept bro jamaran that's a fantastic
name by the way
Oh bro Dameron is III remember that name
so it's just a little real good one yeah
he's been around me there there we go
get ready to do a heavy hit here in a
second I don't care I'm yellow we're
just gonna go for it anyway alright I
mean that's fine if it was anything else
I guess I should have been you know more
proactive and all that stuff but
whatever it doesn't even matter exactly
that's how I feel right now so you know
I'm just want this on PC now seem to be
oh I can't wait actually I'm looking
forward to playing it again I think just
maybe maybe he's a different weapon a
different weapon I can I can you play as
the other gender now and I can see Oh
same I can go female to which I normally
do in most games but I went male this
time because some of the armor looks
better to me yeah on the male but
there's definitely pros and cons for
both there's actually a really
interesting thing that we can talk to
about today with that - they finally put
out a free dlc to redesign your
character oh hi network LAN cable
connection what I mean here by myself
now you left you you just teleported out
yeah dude I don't know shoot I guess
this is a solo hunt now I'll be eating
my max potion now that's never happened
to you guys right I'm you know it's how
it goes
so this is a low rank - deducted arena
quests that I believe came out today
it's the second challenge quest
so we're just we're knocking that out of
the way then we're gonna hit up the the
two high ranks that happens I can just
leave all right time to matter true you
might actually be able to rejoin me I
just killed my birdie you're still
struggling I see you over there it's
dead no let's see abandon turn to the HQ
I feel like a scrub now that I abandoned
but you know that's fine it has one's a
low rank guys we're just warming up
starting the day oh cheese blocks yeah
take it take it as it comes you can't
just jump right in you know it's a
there's a story that you go through and
then once you kind of get to the endgame
it's kind of like destiny ish in the way
you know like you know there's more
stuff more monsters to hunt arm where
you want to like you know get and you
got to get farther in the game too I'm
an offline mode what I just get like all
disconnected I don't know I'm about to
find out just gonna keep flying around
in the air network network please test
internet connection sounds like some
Smash Mouth lyrics going on in the chat
right now and I'm very into that yeah
yeah that's that's very own brand no
looks like my connection works I want to
just dropped out of monster huh well if
you would like to to join in and and
finish off this last fight anyone in the
chat we've got that that Cole ID number
do you think your things still posted I
don't think so this people were just
joining so I think it's so good no I
can't do join right now must be like
offline in here
yeah put in that number that hot session
ID yeah yeah squad up get in do that
thing yeah I'm totally offline right now
go title screen dual wielding guns now
the ebony and ivory will probably be a
you know that might be the closest we'll
get it it's probably an emo sure save my
progress I hope they bring tigrex back
to cult as a really good fight very a
very dangerous monster that I enjoy
fighting don't you want to see something
new though I would assume by this point
yeah but I mean there's also like with
bringing back monsters that I like
getting sets in weapons back that I like
so it's kind of like a big big
everything kind of deal like I want
I think the monster I want the most back
is the the gormogon uh so I love that
monster so much no it's funny I can't
see the oh wait maybe I can let me say I
can't see the session ID right now
reminds me of Dragon's Dogma Dark Souls
and Vindictus all together so it's
actually kind of interesting I believe
part of the team that makes Monster
Hunter actually helped make Dragon's
Dogma which is why they're very similar
yeah savants search for this bad boy
nice I'm just getting read extracts all
day don't even know what that means
so now I kind of do but yeah I'll do you
actually is it actually case sensitive
yes only the first two letters
capitalized I think I think so yeah
they're they're very few capital letters
this time here we go here we go come on
your Wi-Fi we're not on Wi-Fi it's just
I have corporate Internet we're trying
to actually circumvent that I'm hoping I
got a nice little update later today
when I talk to engineering thank you
fix fix all that NAT type hekia we don't
want no NAT type so I feel like a lot of
people kind of enjoyed the the gormogon
that fought them apparently it's the
Monster Hunter designers like favorite
monster they've made I was reading in
like an interview somewhere and it's
just really cool and although the
weapons are like this really cool kind
of like scaled like black and dark
purple kind of like evil looking thing
it's really cool cannot connect a
session because it no longer exists or
the IDS in correct shoe maybe I typed it
in wrong why though we're we're on our
way you have any more chances this is
this is fine
we're okay it's gonna eat this soup any
now that's weird that was a small that
wait for me wait for me bed I'll wait
right here well we'll see if you can
sharpen sharpen I was gonna I was gonna
build up anticipation oh you know you
know there's some killers lyrics going
on here now again this is a very good
time I'm way into this
looking about this game is your Health's
energy just vanish this for no reason
outside of combat yeah the the gradual
kind of like deteriorating of your your
buffs is kind of a downside but it'd be
kind of interesting if we found a way to
kind of circumvent it's also part of it
this is taking too long
right oh maybe I'll make it in for it it
ends but not a big deal probably I'm so
not used to how slow this bug is and
it's driving me nuts attack big giant
beetle oh you got lightning flapped I
think it happens it happens to the best
of us you know out of here also watch
you just can't join back in I probably
can would not be shocked Ben yeah right
100% whenever I would be though because
of trying to make like an electricity
pun you would be shocked exactly
oh maybe says join quest mmm-hmm
let me in oh no it's over the limit it
says there's only one of two that's it's
because it's it's got our good friend
left the question there I've [ __ ]
can't believe this
oh it's ones clapping for me someone is
rigor hanky honky Kong what's up man
whoa you face painted up what's up black
spider how are you guys doing man you
guys are going ham on that on that
clapping I don't even use the emotes
we're out here we're done cool well we
got two boys here to killin it stick a
four-way over us got it I'm not liking
it so that's the other really funny
thing the health bars in Monster Hunter
previously have been much larger than
these ones it's kind of a thing that I
miss look at your awesome weapon it's
all right
charge no it's an alliance that's uh
that's a chart Desiree charge blade yeah
charge blade the terrible attempt at a
pun still very early yeah we're only
warming up it's true
we're only lighting up Oh yikes oh yeah
so I think next is the the Ergon quests
which is going to be a heck of a time
and I hope how come his name's or what
is going in the the wrong wonder do we I
don't I don't know how its set up so I'm
kind of just doing my thing so I think I
might attempt this with with my charge
blade
I'm trying to try to get it going this
doesn't work then I'll just reach it
right oh this is this is ridiculous I'm
gonna close the game and come back in
cuz I guess that's like the only way
because the game treats me as like
offline right now
I'll give you on the count of three yes
for life thanks she's vlogs but uh
anyone else I have a feeling though if
it's gonna keep happening like that
though I wouldn't be shocked I'll say is
anyone else having having issues like
getting into the game at all well let's
find at home don't read chat Tay alright
you got it
Josh no stop reading chat alright now
we're getting are getting so do I need
to do this
again I can see I can send you in any
way oh can you just do that yeah you're
still online yeah yes zooming it works
now okay yeah it does
blam oh this is ridiculous
can't believe this what happens when
you're on an older ps4 I guess on today
of all days
a monster hundred Friday it's a horrible
place
Ted this is China join no dad I'm
joining first we got we got tons of room
in here tons of tons room for people to
hang out and do cool things and arm
wrestle arm rest take my spot when I
disconnect my arm wrestled you yet Tay
no I think we should probably do an arm
wrestle all right before we head off
into this actual hut no I don't want to
embarrass you that badly Oh got me but I
got me having connection issues too hmm
a lot of problems logging into Monster
Hunter lobbies maybe there's something
going on with Monster Hunter then I
don't know they seem fine right now
those guys thing get kick these guys are
chilling having a great time well as
long as we know failed to join the
session hmm maybe worth checking uh like
a Twitter thing
maybe that's what earthing see if they
maybe have a post up about things I'm
having an issue Stream broke the server
huh you know I wish I could I really
wish I could say that was the reason why
it'd be a cool thing to add to your your
list of things to do one time I broke
monster honor servers by just playing
the game it's really weird like there's
nothing going on that would cause like
an issue maybe they're trying to like do
some sort of weird maintenance and
someone tripped over a server to get
ready for next week yeah t-bone got in I
think it's loading now okay okay because
at least I'm getting this like weird
that loading thing yeah loading thing
there we go there we go I heard some
noises Oh juice blocks
people showing up now this is good okay
okay yeah just be ready to take my spot
cuz I have a feeling I'm gonna drop out
again so I think these quests are also
the ones where you can kind of have like
joining in progress happening so yeah
it's fine probably that'd be better for
it yeah hopefully it doesn't do one of
those things where like it doesn't let
you join because of singing can I can I
see it from down here yeah all right all
right cool
I'm not running up there all right I'm
gonna go in a quest what is it I'm gonna
use a voucher because I believe in us
available quests it should be or that's
available here in a second
you're trying now there we go yeah which
one are you going to just one for
southern camp one whatever I can always
fly to you exactly I'm not using a
voucher because I don't believe wow
that's also there's a lot of money on
the on the line actually yeah yeah I'm
using my time I'm gonna try to use the
charge blade embarrass myself that's
fine so that's gonna be a thing or maybe
I shouldn't should I should I not you
want
fortunately we we're gonna have to
probably mute some of y'all which is
just how it goes
I need him on some random session to
collect the guild cards for trophy okay
you call so good calm and just take all
these receipt are we waiting for the
fourth person probably uh it might be a
good thing to do
oh look someone else is eating through
these tables are filled I want to eat to
send out my guild card get it alright uh
everyone's everyone's eating everyone's
had a good time
I just ate but I figure we still had
time is there not like is there another
one that we also oh wait we gotta wait a
second friend your's joining awesome
it's all good just be ready to join I'm
a feeling 8a is gonna drop out of that
scrub watch everyone's gonna drop out
and I'm gonna have to fight them both by
myself with a weapon I'm not good with
that's fine
dan I don't think I can come by today
and by the way just so you know
last-minute secondary stream here and we
do some attack on Titan too later we're
gonna kill some Titans me and Ben double
work we are doing an on confident weapon
and only medium armor and I used a
voucher on it you know it's gonna be a
good time now you it'll be fine I didn't
bring any dumb pods I guess I should do
you think they fight each other or do
you even think they roll up together
whatever I will find out I am good time
whatever it's fine yeah yeah I sent you
a DM it's all good okay no worries I can
maybe like meet you though to drop it
off this psycommu drop it off drop it
like it's hot
yeah I like it that can't believe this
Weezy
young mula baby no but subscribe alright
I'll stop that's all good cop car God
dang it dude wheezy's great man come on
Weezy sure yeah are you you know like
Weezy oh yeah I landed on top of it sick
oh you're already there I just took
where are you at one camp one no so I
didn't get dropped off at a campus oh
you just straight up okay we're coming
to you me and black spider yeah along
came a spider should I jump him should I
jump him I'm gonna join you should jump
on just do it we'll be there in a second
is that like in the front area it's sort
of like down the ramp a bit yeah I see
you I see you black spiders are one of
them oh maybe me and black flare just
fighting a completely different one
where are you guys oh you're afraid they
come to you cuz mine ran away okay I hit
him in the tail I did not put my
Rocksteady men on that was a noob
mistake he got his roar off on me it's
all good
oh he's just like sitting there he is
head I don't know what it is right now
maybe because I just watched The
Avengers trailer this morning what his
he kind of reminds me of Thanos his head
first yeah he's got that that chin that
learned that real strong the Jay Leno
chin
oh I mounted him there you go ho get
stabbed
you've got a pal over there who's gonna
jump off and yeah that'd get netted oh
go to town everyone go to town well you
know what I forgot to do I always forget
I polished him now so I'm supposed to
like jet like sharpen before a thingy
yeah oh I hope I don't trip you guys
with that move
oh nice he's down again I get tripped
too much I'm doing alright alright so I
need to do this I need to do this load
up my shield go back in load it up
hit that thing you think Faramir is
fighting that other one by himself I
hope not it wouldn't be the first time
we've had people just go off in oh he's
in some waffles don't mind me sharpening
over here how do you think alright he's
after me her guns probably a good one to
practice my guard points on - oh he
dodged my big dick my big damage move I
always wanted to get good with the
charge blade but it seemed daunting so I
was like man there's a lot going on with
it like it's a it's a real heck of a
thing oh thanks Ryder's daughter broke
it's not what I need ooh this is
definitely not what I need Oh
again spicy whoa he just sent my
teleported on my screen huh seems like
you're uh having a bit of an issue no I
just hit him I got my jump on it wasn't
enough oh no he's in is this a sleep-gas
yeah it is us to sleep gasps oh it's 90
night I'm it's a good nap time group nap
no kindergarten you know don't do it I'm
no yep mm-hmm
all right guys how's everyone doing
we're taking a little nap here come on
you're good next potion time now is the
time for a max potion oh man I
I got this we're all together
everything's fine oh you would thought
that would have mounted him it did not
yikes
I'm just gonna try to like I'm gonna
line this saw it out I'm not gonna line
that up because I'm gonna hit from
behind sweet oh I'm gonna get rolled on
feels good man but does it though
not really yeah it's alright that's why
I go the double defensive mantle route
just go for the hit whoo I'm on top baby
there we go that maybe we can get a
carve on this guy's tail I can get a
discharge off your running dude oh he's
trying to go to that wall no sir he
doesn't want me to chop his tail off hey
stop making me brace come on No
there it is nails on you nailed it and I
lost connection
oh no everyone left everyone why no I'm
joking when you said you're gonna have
to do it yourself
I can't that's hilarious I'm just gonna
I'm just gonna carve this tail are you
still only using swag axed a yeah right
I haven't played in a while I only play
like every now and then I'll do the
limited bounties and I'll do the new
guys here oh you gotta new guys
I mean new guy like the other one that
we didn't fight I don't know what to do
here should I just kill him he's like
he's like sleeping to Megas he wanna
capture him oh that's a good call I
actually died I was shocked rap on me I
don't think I brought it I did not we're
just gonna have to kill this boy so be a
it'll be just a solo fight then where me
on me on one monster but it's scaled for
multiplayer oh really
yeah so it when when everyone leaves
it's still scaled for multiplayer which
means this it's a more difficult fight
that's fun
so it's a run right into the fire you
know and not as a metaphor but like
actually for real just run another fire
that's fair
I in the back of my mind I was like I
shouldn't bring the charge axe I'm still
learning how to do like this he knew but
here we are I'm still you know we're
gonna do this I believe in you
I'm asleep out sure which means we've
got to do it it's gonna happen can't
really coach you or help you right now I
got I got my owner got a problem right
now
that's all good I'd you're dealing with
your thing I'm doing my thing we're all
dealing with other thing I really wish
had a trap though it would have made
that cap like capturing would have been
a lot easier than what I'm having to go
through right now
yeah oh he's not doing sleepy gas
anymore he's doing fire no hello please
don't please don't stay over there oh
he's getting real uh mad is yours real
mad uh he's rolling around my guys
dropping a lot of exploding balls and
that's never good there we go get that
mound here we go Mountain I am curious
now if there is just something going on
with with the server's then because it
wasn't just you they could have been us
it could be our internet maybe because
you're the host right believe so yeah
you normally host though on Fridays yeah
so like this is the first time we've
ever had issues happening yeah dang
Dan's 146 that's double what I am but I
basically stopped playing I got a lot of
tempered investigation still too
oh he got tired after all that rolling
around though I guess I am I actually
all the other ones here should what is
happening this guy's almost dead isn't
that a good thing yeah but like how did
we get here because we hurt him a lot
this is this is the fresh one though oh
really well you know if n we could have
been fighting the other one that whole
time oh yeah that's right that's weird
black spiders in my online session now I
don't sure we're still in the same
session we just got disconnected from
the actual the fight yeah it seems that
oh we fell over come here get out of
here with that whatever you're doing to
me right now
how is this guy not dead I've laid waste
into him come on get away wha
no I I killed one of them don't turn
your face over here get early I hope my
other ones weak like yours is cuz I mean
he's he just got weak after I was
messing around with him a bit like it
was it's real weird
I don't know goob I don't know what the
the challenge would be unfortunately
sorry thanks everyone for tuning in
remember you can join our session ID if
you want to yeah as we you know do some
of these weekly challenges and events
and things like that we were carrying
killing double Aragon's we were all
together at one point not so much now no
and I would assume that if no one's
joining your match that something must
be borked is my guess that or the game
is telling us that you just can't do
that or something yeah oh no is he's in
the he's in the cool area and I don't
think I brought in cool drinks with me
oh my god what's up he's doing his
rolling around thing yeah he gets tired
eventually yeah if there's if there if
that's anything it's not a it's not a
good look it's not a good look at all oh
okay I didn't realize you fainted until
I looked over when you said it wasn't a
good look I'm gonna go fight this other
one
he's uh he's almost done though it was
good I guess
don't forget to eat them wiggly ichi's
or whatever juice man where is this sov
yet sessionid doesn't exist anymore
hmm I'll have to double check on that so
maybe it's you as false because it seems
oh you know that feeling when uh dude
rolls around and like you're like about
to go find him and then he just like you
know goes to where you were just at yeah
yeah it's not it's not a good time
using an SLS flare oh my dude I feel
like I've got something to prove it yeah
I think so I agree it's like we're
almost out of this we're almost through
it this multiplayer
level up wait double fights over there
yeah I'm um I'm on my way he's actually
sleep or chillin where the other guy was
previously so here we go
hi sharpened please be weakened my
Brenner ears efforts do not let his his
efforts be in vain
I don't know if this is close enough
don't think it is
he'll be fine I need to man if those
were basil geese things I would have
exploded way sooner see hit this hit
that okay yeah we might have to update
the session ID we'll see after this well
take it as it as it happens trying to
not don't worry about that it's too hard
yeah oh hello right into it we're just
gonna roll away anyway come on
I can't believe what I'm seeing with my
eyes that's how good you are Oh God he's
been a real pain right now doing a lot
of Rollie pollie you tired yet there we
go nope not tired yet come on
give me another good one no it's not so
great you know I'm kind of kind of sad
that we're having as many issues getting
getting all of our hunting party
together yeah as long as it doesn't
happen next week during deviljho Yeah
right
it's fine I mean par for the course a
game oh I'm definitely dead
you got you got one more faintly one
more you ever do that trick if you can't
eat I have a mushroom answer set so that
I can eat mushrooms and pretty much get
the same kind of like benefits yeah yeah
that's a pretty good I started to put
together the set for that you just need
the swine mask that's the one part
because it's like plus to mushroom
answer the other part is really easy to
make you only need level 3 mushroom
answer to get full benefit gotcha
like I'm and Agoura Devils play nitro
shroom and you pretty much will get like
a lot of the same benefits you would
have gotten if no G's doing all right
just sitting in the room ok so that's
that's good that that's still going I
wonder what know what's going on with
everything else no no he tripped himself
while his sharpened so this might
actually he might have run away and we
might be able to capture him is he still
here yes he is do it not asleep don't do
it well you could if you think he's weak
enough yeah I think he's agitated though
he's real agitated he was the other one
was agitated for me but this one he's
he's a little tired right now
so that's who wild swing sharpening
probably be a good time actually I am
I've knocked off all of his important
parts so let's get you frustrated with
it also I'm if I understand right if you
do like the what is it like this thing
like you can kind of like ignore too
much of that if you're in the heat of
the moment which is kind of nice flip in
Dyson vacuum just like Oh turn on a dime
for me at all get out of here it's no I
don't roll are you rolling wait someone
told you to sharpen it'll be fine for
always okay so all sharp now here we go
come on just ran away more well you look
good maybe he's going to sleep good
night night all I need right now maybe
he's not oh he disappeared did I just
not see him do you think he oh no he
went down like way down yeah not off to
the side oh boy how many in the room I
am not sure
all right let's do this can we why are
you rolling backward knocked down yes
maybe mine's going to sleep let me see
let me see you are you gonna sleep so I
can go trap your ass oh he is going to
sleep Ben time to go back to camp dude
you got this
surfing USA how many in the room now
hard to say how many are in the actual
session idea I mean I see people joining
in the session ID yeah so I'm not sure
if it's just maybe Ben might I'm
actually like like disconnected fully
and so that's why what I'm seeing people
joined - oh you are yeah it's weird then
I don't I don't even know anymore
who is happening what on ps4 will fight
the guard point was good nice we're
gonna do some more hunting and all that
in a little bit and then eventually
we're fight is that in Geneva so if we
finish this up we can we can hit up soon
achieve a right away oh yeah
yeah okay look at you getting all fancy
yeah right maybe we want DC this time
maybe probably not though
[Music]
are you kidding no go out get out of
here and where's my trap there's a trap
where the high-ranked bombs there the
tranq bombs I'm like tranq his ass I'm
just so you know I wasn't lying
see I trained his ass swapping back to
depend struggles it's uh it's a real
crazy time over here I got his tail off
though hey that's that's a thing that's
a thing I only broke apart oh no there's
some minerals here yeah ova Jesus son
aka trunks what's up oh hey I ended up
buying dragon well fighters instead of
this was it a good choice I mean with
the name like Vegeta you probably made
the right choice for yourself yeah you
you went the right way for for you but
if you wanted more long-lasting gameplay
unless you're gonna play a lot of online
fighting or matches I think this Monster
Hunter if you enjoy the gameplay of this
would a velocity longer what I mean
never know you could get your fill of
Dragon Ball maybe you go sell your copy
and then buy this mix oh uh yeah hello
I'm you know hello hello welcome yeah my
two gigabyte sync connection is the
problem huh I don't know
ooh hello to the people that I can hear
in the session ID so you don't think I
could join you now probably not if no
one else be able to join you oh my god
like that you attempted it
you're real bold well I'm just I'm
trying to like get used to doing guard
point stuff and so that you can die oh
you got so lucky that Hank your boy
hanging in there this so the guard
points are like that's the cool stuff
you can do with this and I don't know
like I won't get that down so I'm taking
like stupid race yeah that's one of
those things where it's like two full
kind of thing a bunch of people like
left a quest so we can't help you out
which makes sense because nobody's been
joining oh yeah that was one hit of the
like what three
I heard three that you can get those can
write a lot more cuz that was thousand
dozen I might say that was a bad hit
get out of here right now
oh this is great they're commentating
about your gameplay here yeah yeah I
think I'm gonna not use the chart I'm
listening to their mic for the funny for
the rest of ya it's it's not pretty I
probably shouldn't have done it
oh I can I can hear it adjusts just to
have a cool drink on me I had to grab
one from the the box there we go there
was a point in time where I just started
keep the villains in the gathering hub
well where are these guys look at they
are low din I'm sure they're there yeah
that's me yeah yeah see this Phoenix
guys knows what's up oh hey what's up
hold on hold on what isn't he oh damn
everyone's here holy [ __ ]
hold on here Ben's here Ben's capturing
no no no there we go we are you guys so
people don't know this but if I was
actually kind of wanting to do that at
some point because a lot of people don't
know it but you don't necessarily have
to trap tranq after you do damage the
order doesn't necessarily matter you can
you can trap something then you can like
you do it out of order as long as you do
enough damage within the time that it's
trapped you're good that was a heck of a
thing like this look at look at you what
you're not you're missing out here dude
is everyone prints the other Frandsen
this is it how do I even do that
it's the prancy but you might have to
download it if you haven't gotten it
oh they just saw you kill it like a
Rooney's hilarious gonna pull us out
chat people I see should hear you but he
can't hear you right now
not yet what scheme is so grinding that
I sharpen my axe with it it's pretty
good actually I like it oh there's the
applaud how do I eat oh you can do it on
the radio dial huh that's what it is I
was so distracted by the fact that I
actually finished that that I didn't
even say go back to town
haha I'll just keep clapping like an
idiot over here dude that's how you do
it man haha can you chat people here to
notes they can hear me on the stream me
on the stream so it's a little bit
delayed oh man we got Sasuke up in this
sauce guy Sasuke oh my na kuma yes sure
that's about where I was see everyone
people are applauding with you to make
you feel better it's it's all good you
got some charge blade boys you got some
sword and shield that's good sword and
shield you got a look at that green
armor that's a good look got a great
sword maybe I'll just let these guys
join you guys instead I'm gonna go but
go up I'm gonna hang out my charge blade
and no ever use again Oh everyone wants
the Prancing they're saying to do
Prancer you don't that pretty they want
to see it on the stream yeah you're all
those stamps are fire my dude sorry I
don't have I don't have the prancing so
I just got a collapse all it's it's a
it's a free download I highly recommend
getting it I don't do emotes I don't
even do it I don't even I don't even do
emotes in blood-borne I like the like
like halfway through the applaud he just
kind of like points he's like yeah you
dude yeah I see there it's it's just so
trippy yeah because I've been hearing it
in real time what they're saying about
what you're doing on a game it's like I
mean an inception kind of here we go I'm
just gonna do this we're not gonna look
back there you are
Hey look what up everyone he gave up on
charge blade I'm out I'm just gonna
stick to what I know now that's fair I
would too and you know what I should use
the actual uh the other sword because
we're about to fight a the other dragons
and Eva and pretty much hope that
nothing bad happens nothing bad will
happen we'll be fine
everything will be a-okay you know what
may I'll just switch accent oh man I
hear myself it's weird
they pitying you Erik yeah I guess so
raid I think it's raid or read jabber
hey guys I love you guys
we love you too thanks love you'd sue
thank you for showing up read by Nature
is it just Dante costumes weapons and
emos or can you actually play as Dante I
mean the skin makes you look like Dante
it's like when you have the Eloi skin
but we don't know if it's high rank
right yeah I'm guessing it's gonna be
hiring cuz why would they release
something that's low everyone wants to
get in on this look at that lay this
action right here look at this everyone
wants in just just waiting for it here
I'm gonna I'm gonna try to time it with
you so you can you can at least try to
get in cuz you gotta you gotta get the
the z ogu tell me why I do need horns
for the charge blade you ready all right
all right let's do it you know what I'm
gonna use a voucher on this one - yeah I
bow sure enough huh I believe we can do
we need those double voucher days to
come sooner Yeah right it is gonna
happen during the cherry blossom event
in a couple weeks
definitely - vouchers a day I think I'll
at least be logging on each day to use
my - vouchers ah sorry guys
- whoever didn't get in we'll do it
again after this yeah and if you got in
this time Fenrir and V Phoenix let the
other people joins are you good yeah I'm
set I'm killing it
standby standby
I heard the Phoenix say something about
a month worth of streams maybe he
finally got into one I don't know no the
Phoenix is been here oh oh they're one
of the the mainstays a good good friends
way into the carrying they've saved us
many time how many what do you think his
hunter rank is we could've saw probably
through the roof theoretically infinite
he said one more shame and he gets a
free meal voucher heck yeah dude see he
knows we get those those taco meal
vouchers that we give out to everyone
really we have Taco Bell every every 50
hunts that you do on stream with us I
didn't know we were maybe two on
promises like that can't be that bad
that can't be that expensive right
I mean it's don't you send like a $20
gift card and then you have enough for
the the 12 pack and then you also have a
little leftover if you want to get like
a like a burrito or something that's
pretty good oh he's bent as blizzard
probably ooh notice Sam yeah oh this
music I thought this so much so much for
what for just doing it because I wanted
to farm up everything look I gotta be
like I don't know if you guys ate
already you might have ate I'm on top
I'm on top of it I need to fill up my
inventory though alright wow that was
nice sharpen me blade I'm so sugar
already can get into the tent Oh Benner
is going with some poison hammer action
here I think oh he's off with off on his
way
saw me in Phoenix there it's no Taco
Bell here you're on your own
we'll find you like oh good luck been
good del Taco we're like a bee flying in
I mean the boys are going to start
fighting over here way let's do this
thing
he's running around the old boy here
this feels much better okay
something familiar something something
that I going with the flow I'm feeling
it I'm gonna trip you then I want to
trip you know you know I'm gonna ship
you I'm gonna draw you up into the air
you can't trick me I got a Rocksteady
man on
geez how are your ears they're mine
we're fine I'm doing 20% more damage
yeah same here got some a hot agitator
going on yeah man always got that hot
agitator action your boy got nailed by
that one
[Music]
might be able to hop bar no del Taco
there's not one taco French Bob where do
you live I mean not like actually where
do you live but like you think he has a
thingy no he doesn't no it's not it's
not glowing hard enough get me out from
under here
get me out from under there really
hitting what I want to right now I'm I
have a mess I need to I need to focus up
get my business set right again uh not
good okay I'll keep being exact hit by
that sometimes you just gotta take the
laser to this guy take a laser beam it
to the face like so remind yourself
where you came from you know
I think we have talked about in the UK
shoot we should ship Taco Bell outs you
guys so you can experience it and then
know that you probably should never have
it more than that any times that are
necessary but God I'm a trash monster
full of it who charged that oh I saw
that
yikes he Phoenix was going for the big
the big homerun and then he got a hit no
Taco Bell's in the UK you're better off
oh no I'm one of the anti Taco Bell guys
here can't believe this oh I'm gonna hit
his face hit his face nope
get out of there oh that's not good
I don't think he's gonna just like chop
his tail right now I'm gonna get a quick
sharpen while he's coming back down I
got some some good slight slices there
on his a tail Taco Bell closed cause of
poor sales I'm not surprised but oh he's
down kind of
Oh Bom Bom
my swooping here grab this yeah when I
take this time to sharpen because it's
more damage more damage is good and
reach at even a Chipotle would do
Chipotle's fine Chili's pretty alright
yeah
oh okay Oh what
oh there's falling boulders in here uh
yeah I don't I did not know that I was
just on the ball Hawk fight a lot yeah
as a swing in my sword and then they
fell from the ceiling and I don't know
why oh come on come on no I couldn't do
it here we go
can't get a bunch of fast cheap talk
think he's gonna fly away here maybe
yeah yeah there you go
sharpen if you guys want to pick up some
of his uh Scrappy's here to some pods
gotta be rockin that polished Jim man
you need that that polished Jim like I
got one oh good are you it yeah nice so
I couldn't come fit it in another place
it's so oaky man it's real good if you
especially if you have white sharpness
it's like really good yeah I just need a
handicraft three Jim but it's really
hard to get one if you don't spend a lot
of time playing because either got to do
all the optional quests or the rank 100
hundred rank one on your quest yeah
which normally I'm a min/max er but I
even I didn't want to really do it
alright we're going we're going up top
can jump up jump off on top yep Oh or
he's just gonna do stuff alone real
crazy explosion don't mind me while I
take this max potion and you do what you
gotta here we got here we go oh don't
fly up jerk skip we'll bring him down
alright
I hit him with some some piercing pods
there we go
do it on that tail drop that tail hey
yeah now do we do the car while he's
still alive technique I was doing that
last night it was kind of sketch it's
it's definitely dangerous every time but
it's a good time every time that was
pretty embarrassing with tbh it happens
to the best of us yeah that's that's
fair I think I want to say Phoenix is
carving so a bold move oh my god I'm
literally in the worst spot ever please
no just stay on the floor sometimes it
helps do you know what I'm gonna go for
it to do it I'm gonna try to trip him
right here so you guys got that yeah I
love doing my Carver's when the monsters
right over me I know you're fine man
we're doing work to him except you
roared and I probably didn't work out so
good for you fine oh he's flying now is
the time the car right yeah
exactly maybe you won't see me cuz I
dang it come on down nice one a brand
new switch X I still got one more carve
oh please don't track this way I'm good
so this is the good one this is when you
can you can shut him down I'm way into
it right in the junk oh yeah family's
got the idea just did a little nice
whirlwind move he's gonna fall down you
get him in the chest that's that's the
good stuff that's the business there we
go now he's all shut down
thanks for the help darn it
I don't put down a health booster back
over he you know gives away gems like
candy kind of everyone last night but I
think I think it's just cuz you get so
many carbs off of them it's the desire
sense though man you don't want it I
don't need it I need another stupid near
Nagant a gym that thing is a pain in the
ass for me to farm yeah but that's still
like a super serious fight like it's a
dude I was I don't know if it's just cuz
I got used to fighting them I mean like
I haven't fought him in a well a minute
but like my best time killing uh it was
a high rank it wasn't a tempered but
like killing your grantee the other day
I killed him in three minutes 45 seconds
dang and I don't think that it'll ever
get better than that to be honest so the
the one that blew my mind was I saw
someone use a bow to kill him in like oh
that the one where he just kept jumping
on yeah that thing that was real Goods
real good made me wish then I could play
bow well but maybe that just like it
starts right - yeah well tail swipe
Phoenix no okay we're not run on that
thing she's not hey man
anytime Nick I'm glad that we can help
you get through your workday or make it
make anything that much more bearable
I'm happy that you're here yeah thanks
for everyone tuning in we know he's not
charged up man I need oh I got
Rocksteady man already let's go
just keep hitting that guy in the face
that's okay
hi I would like to hit you talking about
the creative process behind Geneva and
we got ideas from monsters
it's a giant spider dragon breeze lasers
you're hired bring this guy in
also real talk that I really kind of
like the design of this this monster a
bit it's it's not my favorite fight
because it's more of like an event fight
it is a spectacle yeah I don't like how
Ganon was kind of a spectacle and breath
of the wild I feel like yeah where if
you had all the tools you needed he
wasn't very hard same with this boss
like near Gigante was probably a lot
harder than this boss yeah and then I
guess that's probably the reason why new
gig on tase the the first check the the
first check but I think also the
flagship monster for this one because
they're like I don't really want to have
this guy be our main our main stand out
my sharpness is butts right now
right
I'm Way far off
hello how's this started long ago we
started about an hour ago we're probably
gonna do this fight one more time for
some of the other viewers and people
that were in the session IDs and some
not everyone got in I don't think yeah
and then yeah
we'll do some attack on Titan later heck
yeah so if you're interested in attack
on Titan - buckle up it's gonna be a lot
of anime nothing wrong with that where
my weebs at nothing wrong with that at
all Paul might hit him in the face don't
care yeah how does it feel it makes like
weird like alien squeaking sounds I
don't that might be my least favorite
part about him he's like an alien dragon
thing we expect
oh come on those should have all hit
[Music]
get another sharp and really quick yeah
squeal for me get um Phoenix
oh it's lit yeah what you did there
yikes
gonna watch the Tomb Raider movie later
oh yeah I'm still curious about it I
want to see it well it didn't my video
like really loved it but then Casti like
hates it so it's interesting toss-up I'm
I trust both of my friends but who do I
trust more you know that's it's what
expectations you have for them for
getting out of that movie I kind of just
want like a look I want it to be like a
big dumb action movie like a summer
action movie kind of it's not summery
that bad I know but that's what I want
it I want that movie to feel like be an
interesting time either way though how
are you not dead yet
oh that's bad
uh-huh I was waiting for this I know
I've got cheersing pods I've been saving
these pods for you help fen were took
what I was gonna take oh no he didn't
come down yet
oh he will so much stuff on everyone
shooting him now here we go there you go
I should be hitting his space for a max
damage here come on
always doing one of those this is
perfect
right in the couch get him shoot hard oh
there is the boy is dead we got him good
job good job
yeah it's one of my my least favorite
fights in the game but it says it is
really cool though but green berry I
don't know I feel like well I'm assuming
you've played the game but for me when I
when I start landing some of those who
are god GEB when you start landing some
of those combos and you start maximizing
your damage it feels real good
also there's like multiple weapons it's
it's weird to me to hear the argument
like plague because it looks good
because I I played like most of the
other ones were it does not look good
and it was just the gameplay was the
reason for playing it yeah yeah I can
see it's not a game for everyone like as
much as I love mobster oh yeah gem I can
say oh nice I can totally understand
people not being into it yeah
and that's okay cuz you don't have to
like games other people like yeah yeah
we live in a good time there's a lot of
there's a lot of good stuff out there
Lauren Breann says why is your favorite
fight you go first
so I'd say probably I like the oh dear
know what like I I love how it's it's
kind of like a low to the ground fast
moving like jumping off a walls at
certain points and I really like where
you fight them to almost the time so I'd
say that might be my favorite in this
one I also farm the crap out of it cuz I
love his armor set yeah uh I'm gonna go
with nerd that's good um good choice
Hey he was very scary he's still scary
not as scary for me now like now that
I've formed them so much I have it's
ridiculous I have like 150 regrowth
plates I've like a hundred like I have
hundreds of everything except gem except
the thing you need yeah cuz that's
that's how Master Hunter goes you never
get what you want but bunch of what you
don't know you want
rocket-powered greatsword is what I
think view Phoenix just said but yeah
yeah that'll be a good one looks real
good this that's why I made the great
sword the phezzan cuz the buffs are
coming for the kite sword and I want to
have I want to get the the
rocket-powered one so it's good call I
kind of want to make the rocket-powered
one as well just to have it's gonna be
good it's gonna be real real rad are we
doing one more of these no soon others
you know gb won't Moria and then we'll
call it a wrap I mean they're gonna get
like a double dose of us today anyway so
I mean oh that's true like that is that
is very true it's a good a good way to
do it I went to the workshop by accident
I did that earlier yeah don't worry my
dude it's I know how you feel it's such
a reflex you just you just want to get
back up to the top level and you don't
need to go anywhere else I'm like not
even used to going to the gathering hub
because like I barely ever go there yeah
like I'm good
Krum says never played Monster Hunter
games before but I'm stuck in Monster
Hunter world now yep same some I'm
really really glad that more people are
giving it a chance and in getting to
play it it's a very exciting time it's
really cool
the moment I saw a commercial for
Monster Hunter World on primetime TV I
was like we've made it Monster Hunter is
a thing that people are noticing and
actually being down with yeah so that's
that's pretty cool
yes good we have another stream later
today it will be at 1:30 2 o'clock I'm
gonna play attack on Titan to animate
Friday yeah enemy Friday yeah I mean I
I've never oh wait
am I not in your keeper the our world 1
I don't think you are yeah how do i how
do I cancel I think you talked to the
person of the desk there's still a spot
for you it's quite still a spot for you
let's click alright still Oh No I've got
to cancel it no it's fine let let friend
we were play with you guys it's cool all
right unless there's another person yeah
we could start up two different ones you
can take up okay sounds good
that's a that's Teddy's do you want to
race you want to race you race you want
a I hate guys I need I need a squad
I'm your squad we got to be number one
here you got to bring all your best best
stuff hold on let me know if we're
racing I gotta go back to my stash here
real quick all right showboat I need to
be able to show both gameplay now we can
try here hold on I mean let me uh
they're not gonna get both audio we just
have yours let's have a race that sounds
like fun
okay legitimately sounds like fun I like
that okay let me I need to get some max
potions and where's I think everything
else is good are we gonna have a race
guys let me set this up we're gonna make
I need to make another window here real
quick and [ __ ] it's on the screen isn't
it I hope we have enough people I think
we do too I don't think we do even it
out yeah yeah okay this is good I like
this is this a double dose you guys were
referring to no the double dose is the
the next stream this is a separate
double dose set yeah it's a completely
separate double dose I guess game let's
put on game - all right so this is this
is me how do we do this without this
looking like completely awkward let's
find out hold on just do like the
classic Capcom when we're like you got
it kind of like one over the other but
that's baby a lot of black space I feel
like we can put a cool picture of
something there you know why is yours
there yeah
you entertained the people why do I try
this oh there you are
so like something like that or some kind
of kind of well make yours bigger we'll
make yours bigger since you're you got
the you got the audio and all that
fair enough and then we'll make wine I
can move it have two webcams oh maybe I
could split the camera the cameras
around oh Jesus
this is taking out a whole thing this is
real good that's not it
give me a second y'all this is gonna be
good this is like a unofficial little
unofficial official race we've got to do
something special for today because
there wasn't really much in terms of
like that's a big one right yeah we got
we got that down time before everything
kicks off this will be real good oh yeah
put a picture of the gormogon in the
background would be a real good time no
that's not it I can potentially what the
deuce wait a second hold on one sec oh
man I'm starting to think about like
what I need to like have equipped what
am i what do I need to do confused right
now oh all right so if I do
I got a crop I got a crop this yes I
like a look at my team already this is a
good team you leave it you don't even
know who you have yet you know what can
you give me a second I'm just saying I
like it I like that you're talking trash
right oh here you go so I gotta talk
trash now before I get no I get work
though
oh there here we go we want to crop me
out of here right yeah yeah we're
cropping me out of there putting like
you up here oh there we go so this is
this is that production quality we look
for this is exactly where we're headed
just move closer no no no you're good
should I put you this way then drama
this over here this is your setup this
is all good you know I'm fine with
whatever we're doing like all right
there's gonna be some flags
bass guys I didn't I didn't really oh
that doesn't overlap though huh
I I got shrink this a little bit maybe
and you know what it's fine I think I
don't have an overlay or this would look
a bit cleaner that's um ooh fenders
bringing out the big guns we got we got
a real nasty looking sword here Oh doing
that getting that flex looking real good
guys hold on what's gonna it's good look
at everyone here so that I knee a crop
looking looking real good
black spider also killing it this is
this is the best team how dare you these
are the best this is the best team it
can't get any better than this
is there okay who who did they want in
the background was a gala ah
the gourmet gala yes it's boy like
morally wrong flag or like like court
like gross gore like a gore like geo ree
geo heart like like ah there you go I
need I need I need large image though
give me the the biggest image you can
find give me a large
ooh oh no that's a wreck though I can't
take that that you get with that guy
yeah guru nice this this is close that's
yeah that's them yeah that's a three 3ds
box are taken from the Monster Hunter
wiki I'm yeah yeah that's him
just blow it up make it look real gross
just I'm still reeling from the other
other results from that image search no
he can fit it's fine it's good just make
him make them real big thank you it
won't let me blow it up more like I'm
trying to blow it up more ven hold on
any a new image damn I thought that was
gonna work or maybe I just do it oh my
god this is getting way too complicated
okay that didn't work you just get that
guy yeah yeah don't steal art that's
from the masaha wiki it's an
informational page happy 10th
anniversary gormogon ah
oh yeah cuz Google did all that changed
how everything works sudden arms arms
mashup I don't know the gormogon arms
character and try my best here yikes oh
here we go here we go okay so can I make
it bigger than that no that's the whole
screen that's fine just take it in yep
he's like you can kind of see him
perfect in the bottom left no purple in
the background we're good alright do a
lot hopefully that did what I wanted it
to okay so
oh there's gormogon uh over I can't
point again I can't point to it either
without it oh there you go
I can I can reach across to it so it's
top left I'm bottom right and let me
switch my I can't believe I tried to
work within the confines of my own box
when I realized that it's not even a
real thing it's okay I did that too we
got I'm bottom right here so I'm gonna
go post you you got it thing right you
got I got I got a post one up I hope
that I have enough folks in my group -
hello Alba you've joined and then we're
gonna we're gonna make we're gonna we're
gonna we're gonna have a little race
here it's hideous it's perfect I love it
alright so I just post this up with four
players you know what I believe in the
voucher I believe in my group that's
avenues about you that's good I'm not
afraid that's real good I I really hope
you know how many of you guys on my team
of a ps4 probes you're gonna load it in
quick hahaha it's real important yeah
we're on even ground here I like this
okay yeah it's gonna be real
embarrassing if you can't get a group
together you know what
I'll see who is faster dang alright I
need I need I need some peeps it doesn't
have to be three I just need some peeps
wait do we even have an RV Phoenix could
join right who else do we got Ted this
Ted this and B Phoenix art nerds walk
through the crowd and coffee please joy
sir get in here
join my race you too
I need you to those other fools over
there think they're gonna win no one's
moving please no no you know what B
Phoenix is changing his armored eye
color or there you go there goes Tet
this there's stream delay Ben you gotta
remember right we gotta take a new
account it's true you gotta remember
stream delay okay cat place your bets
that is a good team Ben is on their team
Ben is up there team Eric is that way
that away that way
I'm on the bottom so far I have no party
members feels good it's gonna happen
eventually you'll you'll get it I don't
know man
I don't know Phoenix please he's
building up the tension the dramatic
tension I don't know why hello I need
help here and oh he's trying to set this
is it now working dude you got a party
you can't even have people join team Ben
all the way it's okay got the solo this
myself this is this is like this is
coming to our our stadium home turf this
is Master Hunter Fridays you know
hanging out being again underdog a wait
team it's all good I'm all I need help
though the underdog needs some help that
that underdog story I'm actually kind of
disheartened that no one's joining you
yet or the techies is trying but having
issues hold on let me yeah I'll try
posting it again okay oh I lost a
voucher though doing that that's fine
you're gonna get a whole bunch more it's
all good I don't like losing vouchers
can you bet in bottle caps we we take
all forms of currency I want you guys to
know I sacrificed a voucher that
for you guys oh no I didn't lose the
voucher all right good
fake motivation for your team I can't
believe vouchers vouchers back in
playboys voucher is back in clay I gotta
make sure I ate I'm too excited I did
okay all right I just posted up in new
quests please help me which quest it
should be the event quest okay it called
something of world's keeper up the other
world keeper of that other world
hello Terrace how are you doing welcome
Phoenix why why do you betray me cuz
deep down V Phoenix no he's not even on
your side why not both solo the only
that's a good question Ben why not both
solo because monster horrified is a
community show all the time this is this
guy ah if you want to go ahead to head
that way if we can't get you a team
together I'm saying that we can split up
this team too I'm basically goading you
into soloing because I don't have a team
you know that's fine oh thanks Bob I
knew someone would you got this check
out that blue armor I know that's pretty
it's pretty dope I like it a lot oh we
got movement where's it gonna go what's
he gonna do oh no I haven't done it yet
I can't even get I couldn't even get a
ringer to hang man you know what oh I'll
go against all four of you luck is that
a fair fight
is that favorite in my favor possibly is
it handicapped my way that way you know
what let's let's do this
what kinda forever let's do this you and
me Oh
singular cuz we've got the setup now we
have to do a race yes we have it we have
to okay sorry guys
if you guys are really desperate and
wanted to do a group thing up you guys
can well I'm willing to stay to let you
guys play with Ben after this as part of
Monster Hunter Fridays however it's
about to go down do you wanna do you
want to do like a like a two-person team
like we can take one person on with us
and that way we can still involve people
oh you like it to do oh sure yeah well
okay one person one personal flash hider
is now on my team that's fine stop there
no way nobody else joined my quest and
you can too all now everyone joining my
team haha I can't believe this they've
all switched so quickly got them maybe
maybe you go three people and then maybe
we hard stop we go 3v3 3v3 yeah three
three on three I'm Dan since maybe since
they know who you are that uh they'll
join your watch everyone we use my oh
jeez duh yeah I see what's going on now
okay all right so I got mine up three
three slots two people can join in oh of
course V Phoenix goes over to the quest
person now you traitor my dude your
fashions awful Wow get out of here
just awful leave it I'll be Phoenix
alone he's so close every - alright
alright let's do this let's let's dance
alright I'm still I'm still eating I'm
still good I'm gonna eat when I get
there they got a man when you get
maximises a speed race I'm next
don't worry about it you do you you do
you you and your group do you you know
you leave me black spider and Fenrir
alone can't believe alright I don't even
know why I gave you that strategy that's
not a strategy already just rad you
watch I'm gonna even sharpen my blade
before I even hitch my ride there I
can't believe this
B of a let's go put your ones in for Ben
put your twos in for Team Eric we're
gonna have to hit depart but as black
spider just edit it's on like Donkey
Kong your whole team's not even ready
look okay they're getting their stuff
front this is fine this it's all good
except why is it oh I could have got a
part here wait well there's no cheating
here there's no cheating
are you ready hold on do we want to like
alright we can do it at the same time I
don't want to hear anything later Ben I
don't want to hear it it's triangles
triangles triangle free you got a
confirm okay fine yeah
this is on you if anything of yours will
take however it goes yours is behind I
don't want to hear it don't want to hear
it oh my god
I thought something really nice Oh black
spider is still preparing I can't
believe yes know what we'll just do a
countdown I think the countdowns a
better lead up anyway oh no he left my
goo oh my goodness is going boys this is
an upset really team been huge trying to
screw me he was sure he was the one that
said it's on like Donkey Kong where the
hell did he go this is the biggest
swerve the biggest he'll turn in the
history of Monster Hunter competitive
racing I've ever seen
blacks oh no he's back he's preparing
skinned McGuinness together everything's
good guys and now you wait okay let's
guys seriously we're wasting a lot of
time yeah this is the build-up this is
the dramatic build-up there were only
three quests this week so we have two
right are you ready vamp summary okay
two one go
oh that's pretty synchronized everyone
can see you can see okay I gotta eat I'm
not listening to you anyway I'm not
talking anymore
guys we got to do this my pride is on
the line so say whatever happens I'm
still your friend after this but you're
definitely gonna toss my microphone and
maybe betray us yep
are we skipping this or annoying that
you'll let it play out okay gotta let it
play out if this is where we get a bonus
if one of our teammates skips it neither
of us aren't a pro so we're on even
playing ground yeah yeah we're all we're
all the same here it looks like you
might be a little bit ahead that's okay
my guys just leave me I'm gonna eat real
fast let's start the fight but don't
even wait for me real talk this is a
race oh man I already screwed up it's
it's the nerves are setting in come on
load faster
yes black spiders got the right idea we
gotta polish our blades off I think
Henry already went cuz he's he's feeling
swaggy alright let's let's do it boys
let's do boys I think I'm the only one
in here right now
yeah Fenrir go to work I think I'm the
only one you'll be remembered in Monster
Hunter Friday GameSpot history if we win
this oh this guy's got pro strats oh
this guy's got pro stats
okay you guys noticed that Ben stopped
talking oh this is because we're racing
man this is real this is as real as it
gets it's not that like I want to jump
on but I think it's the only one I won't
get knocked off of this is also the
worst possible scenario because I
realize that we're not gonna be looking
at chat at all only I could hear what
this guy was trying to tell me to do not
Jude you got it you got to do this whole
fight with feeling you can't you can't
communicate you communicate with your
heart
Oh
I believe in my team though I'm already
feeling pretty good about it I believe
in my team we're all killing it right
now like this is this as good as it gets
oh I almost just got got this is not
good you don't want to get got that's
the the worst possible scenario you lose
points if you oh shoot
Who am was died Real Talk actually same
woo
come on come on
yikes
mmm stand up please
okay here we go this is good this is
this is good that that extra Jam I just
got slapped the first real evidence if
you guys are trying to figure out who's
like ahead in the race will be whoever
gives when whoever gets a phase two or I
think it's the fire thing then it's the
flying away that we need to look out for
there we go you knocked down you
distracted me I looked at your school
all part of the plan
like it's like screen cheating all over
again oh god oh come on don't do this no
okay
oh that's good what okay flu baby yeah
yeah are you in here all the same not so
yeah team Eric let's go shoot conga go
black spider we got this sharpen your
blades boys oh no how far behind are we
don't know depends on when your guy
flies hello
oh no I'm sure now
oh no B Phoenix does shook now good
stagger get staggered oh my goodness all
those tails off I think whoo oh my
goodness
good job boys this is this is looking
looking kind of rough this is looking
real rough oh no oh my god we might we
might we got card out of this card out
of it
I've I can't remember though I've died
on this I'm not gonna say anything yet
I got to make sure we complete the
mission I gotta bring this boy down oh
my goodness he just caught on fire
he's down he's down come on oh he's
really down
come on
oh that's the most basic level mistake
and I did it I can't I can't believe
where I am right now ha ha
he's got smacked oh come on he's
vulnerable oh no he fainted no black
spider it's okay it's fine it's okay
that's fine okay we're just flying away
now
oh that's just whiffed swift city you're
okay we got two more faints plenty of
plenty of time here okay all right I
don't think the size affects the HP pool
I don't I don't know if our our sizes
are too different either oh nice work
oh I am definitely rushing and making
making mistakes well I'd like to maybe
hit him once here same Oh or get smacked
alright black spiders back in the fray
oh my goodness come on this is going
well boys I feel it I get knocked back
when I get knocked back don't do it
always though he doesn't have the energy
[ __ ]
oh my god that is about as bad as I can
get
oh I did not mean to reload there you
had a very inopportune reload as well
whoa whoa come on I don't think he's got
the energy to Slamma jamma oh no run
black spider oh there goes the tail nice
alright that's good that's good just
keep it going I don't understand how
this guy isn't dead feel like my whole
team has been going ham on him Oh Rock
Steady's ready come on
get out of here
they missed the big money pay out there
oh this is good this is good
because he's not dead yet the most
scientific we should have won by now oh
man I don't know if we can make the the
ketchup for this at all but oh man we're
we're trying though
whoa lasers don't know why I went for
his head there oh this is good though go
ham I don't have any go ham on him oh no
oh yeah time first time baby I can't
believe it
dang well I I admit defeat it was a
funny oh don't be sorry at all
we did it it was a fun race yeah yeah I
had some ringers I knew I've been I knew
I thanks guys for joining hey pal Dan
been mode Fenrir thanks for joining Tom
my phone so he can he had a good time I
appreciate you guys welcome in here to
tour our cool we'll hang out we have
woof oh wait they haven't even not yet
No
goodness great work look out a horn
that's what I needed for my New Yorker
Gant a great sword that was that
something that was something I know I
think I should start doing more yeah I
see should do this with John Luke once a
week yeah I think you guys should have a
competition crazy whatever the whatever
the biggest party event is yeah I think
so that was fun a lot of fun huh that
was a lot of fun we accidentally
discovered a fleet yeah thank you
community we did it
how are you guys new ways for deviljho
that would be yes actually let's go I'm
a dog without telling John Luke about it
we're gonna have a race he's watching
right now he's not he's playing this
playing God war probably he's getting
ready to get on a phone rematch versus
deviljho I won't be here next week
John Luke will be though that your
original and normal monhun Friday group
but yeah thank you to my teammates
Fenrir and black spider see one of them
knew about the rocks in the first area I
was like this is a good thing when I
first ran in that was the first thing I
did I did it worked I was like oh man
I'm gonna hit that first thing that's
smart
that bonus I need to go back and look at
the recount of the chat so I can see how
many people actually didn't think my
team was gonna do it cuz I'm pretty sure
there's a lot of doubters Ben ID same I
think they are all I'm so wondering why
were so far behind stefanos is team Ben
oh thank you I appreciate you guys
willing to watch a my super scientific
terms you're darn right yeah we did see
the New Avengers trailer yeah yeah we
got a I think someone did a breakdown of
it too I think we're up from GSU if we
haven't done it it's on the way yeah
well point out although the cool little
things that are inside well team taste
suffer disconnection issues we didn't
they're rushing too hard you're making
lots of mistake I as soon as you guys
started to fly away yay
trying to go hey I was like oh no and it
was
it was it was downhill from there yeah
and then like once we got to the other
side it's like ooh we chopped his tail
off like I was like right away I was
like give me like updates on it I'm like
oh no what is happening right now
not a single pearl answers as Jose Luis
actually one of my friends is a Lancer
and he's actually really good with that
he likes it so I kinda want to learn to
use one just so I can like have the
experience after charge blade but you
guys saw where I am with charge blade
right now so it's probably not gonna be
for a while loser definitely had the
violence at anvil and game a week ago we
can add that into the fold
yeah there you go my shoes will do when
I'm not here
rematch on great job Chris what it
happen sold to injury it's okay guys I
knew our team was good I believed in all
of you and you're all fantastic I'll
take I'll take I'll take I'll shoulder
that entire blame was on me all right
well yeah that was a monster hunter
Friday god that's a great time I I'm
glad we discovered something
accidentally for you guys to do I
actually want to see the devil Joe race
I think that'd be a fun time to our
competitors and teammates that helped us
this week definitely come back next week
as you embark on a scary journey yeah
right um but thanks man that's a lot of
fun yeah yes yeah we'll be back shortly
probably in about an hour and a half or
so we're gonna do some attack on Titan -
that games coming out next week what
we're gonna be able to show you guys I
think you're roughly it's a 10 hours
your timers I'm like 10 hours into the
game like 50% the way through so there
isn't I don't think you have to worry
about story spoilers yeah story we'll do
some of that open roaming stuff there's
like you could just kind of go in and
yeah like rkd kill stuff so come back in
about an hour and a half check that out
again appreciate you guys all tuning in
and of course Monster Hunter Friday's is
every Friday next Friday is gonna be
jam-packed though so we'll have to
figure that one out
we've got some fun stuff coming next
week there's a lot of stuff coming next
don't know how much of this stuff I can
say but just know you know there's going
to be a lot
James laughs fun times ahead and of
course we do appreciate you guys all
tuning in and come back next week every
day or come back in an hour and a half
come again next week come but don't
leave me
look at those stickers hold on let me I
got a good sticker yeah that's a good
sticker up dammit well way too bad
anyways thank you guys see you guys in a
little bit we appreciate it
goose
[Music]